[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now president
biden says he hopes the conflict between
israel and the palestinians will stop
sooner than later we'll speak with one
of the israeli government's top advisers
as well as palestinian campaigners the
middle east minister james cleverley
will be with us
in a few minutes plus a new warning if
you've been doing your own
dentistry during the lockdown plus
how a viral video of a dementia sufferer
playing the piano has helped create a
new
national support scheme and also this
morning how a jog along brighton
seafront with fellow cancer patients
gave the author josie lloyd inspiration
for her new book it is thursday
the 13th of may
airstrikes and rocket attacks between
israel and gaza
president biden says he's hopeful for a
swift end to the violence
my expectation hope is that
this will be uh closing down sooner than
later
but uh israel has a right to defend
itself
the former prime minister's question
time david cameron to appear before mps
to explain his lobbying
for the failed finance company
greenfield capital
killed by covid the teachers in rural
india who lost their lives after being
forced to work in the elections will
bring you a special report
brace yourselves orthodontists offer
some wisdom about
teeth and the dangers of online
treatment
the end of the line the french
trawlerman fearing for the future unless
the fishing row with jersey
is resolved
and low pressure stays close to us over
the next few days so we're looking at
showers or longer spells of rain but not
always in the same places
so for today's details join me later in
the programme
a very good morning to you hamas
militants have launched a series of
rocket attacks at israel
after israeli airstrikes killed
commanders in gaza
president biden has said he backs
israel's right to defend itself and that
he hopes the attacks between israel and
the palestinians
will be closing down sooner than later
america is sending an envoy to the
region at least 67 people in gaza and
seven people in israel have died since
the violence fled up
on monday well our middle east
correspondent mark stone has the latest
and just to warn you
you may find some elements of his report
distressing
[Music]
in gaza city this is what israel's
retaliation looks like
a direct hit on the al-sharook tower
it's not yet clear if anyone was inside
the office block
but it is clear that for another day
gaza is crumbling
at hospitals the length of the strip
ambulances shuttle the injured for
treatment
the israelis insist that they are only
targeting terrorists
that civilian deaths are regrettable
among the rubble hamid al-yasri tells us
how israeli intelligence called his son
to say their home in a block was about
to be hit and that they should leave
[Music]
the beauty hikes up a little bit
as he explains the sound of another
attack
his story is an illustration certainly
of an attempt by israel to limit the
casualties
but then in this tiny enclave there
isn't anywhere really safe to be
and their homes of course have gone
they're left to retrieve what they can
this israel says is the objective video
from the military showing a strike which
they say killed the right-hand man
of hamas's top military commander
hamas fired hundreds of rockets back and
suggested all options were there
mutual ceasefire or keep going
if they want to escalate the resistance
is ready if they want to stop
the resistance is ready they want to
move their hand out of jerusalem
the resistance is ready this is the
message that we delivered
to all the sides and to whoever is
involved
but miles to the north this renewed
conflict and the history behind it has
spawned something else
this is batiyam near tel aviv israeli
jews attacking arabs
in cities across the country there are
riots between the two sides
between tel aviv and jerusalem the arab
community were protecting the mosque
into the evening
we spent the afternoon in the town and
we saw the rubble from the clashes of
the previous night
when jews said arabs attacked them the
point is this
isn't the palestinian west bank this is
a city in the very heart of israel a
place where israeli jews
and palestinian citizens of israel had
been living
alongside each other now they're
fighting
it represents a dangerous change prime
minister benjamin netanyahu visited some
of the towns
this is a huge challenge that some say
he's stoked
we are continuing our efforts to stop
the anarchy and restore governance to
the cities of israel
with an iron fist if needed with all
forces needed
and all authorities required
across the atlantic the u.s president is
watching every angle of this
fresh middle east crisis it is his first
regional test
my expectation and hope is that
this will be
closing down sooner than later but uh
israel has a right to defend itself when
you have thousands of rockets flying
into
your territory
yes in the hours after he spoke this is
what gaza looked like more israeli
airstrikes
hamas hit back with a sustained attack
on tel aviv
and rockets which reached further north
into israel than ever before
mark stone sky news in jerusalem
well let's talk to the middle east and
north africa minister james cleverley
good to see you this morning the united
nations says this is
escalating towards war do you agree
well i don't want to speculate about
what might happen next what
the uk has called for what uh countries
around the world have called for
is for this to de-escalate for
both uh the uh the the government of
israel
and the palestinians particularly hamas
to step away from this
so that we don't see any more casualties
we don't see any more fatalities
and we can start working towards a
sustainable peace
how can tensions be de-escalated at the
moment it doesn't look as though any
sarge is going to step away from this
well the foreign secretary uh has spoken
with the
foreign ministers of both the
palestinian authority and of
israel i've spoken to the respective
ambassador
and uh and the the representative of the
uh palestinian
uh authority in the uk and the
ambassador to israel
we're speaking with international
partners we are we are working very very
hard to take the attention
out of this situation to encourage both
sides to step away from what could be
a a terrible escalation
and to resume cooperation get back to
the negotiating table because it is in
nobody's interest
for this to escalate further why did you
say
just a moment ago that it was more
important for
hamas to take a step back from this
it's it it is important for both sides
to take a step back we have seen however
an
unprecedented uh level of rocket attack
into israel uh as president biden said
in the clip that you showed
israel has the right to defend itself we
have always said
that in doing so they must uh seek to
minimize
civilian casualties something which you
highlighted in the clip that you showed
but ultimately
what we want to see as a de-escalation
we want to see the rocket attacks
stop we want to see no more
injuries and fatalities and that's what
the uk
as part of the international community
will be working towards yeah but i mean
you've said yourself it is vital that
all actions are proportionate in line
with international humanitarian law
uh are you satisfied that what israel is
doing
it is in line with humanitarian law with
with so many civilian casualties and we
know
we think about 14 of them children
that's got to raise some questions
hasn't it
well gaza is um perhaps one of the most
densely populated parts of the of the
world
uh israel's actions are in response to
rocket attacks by
hamas that endangers the palestinian
people
in gaza both directly and indirectly
um as i said in the uh house of commons
yesterday we expect
israel to make every effort to minimize
civilian casualties but
ultimately the best way of doing so is
for the rocket attacks to stop
for uh israeli uh for uh israel to no
longer feel the need
to um to strike targets in gaza
and that we de-escalate this situation
and get
back to cooperation between the
palestinian authority and the government
of israel
and moves towards a sustainable peace so
so you're quite confident are you that
that
through all of this israel is just
acting as a
in in the defensive way whereas i mean
laila moran said in the comments
yesterday
that israel's actions in sheikh gerard
which is one of these
territories where where palestinians are
being moved out
actually contravenes the fourth geneva
convention
well we should recognize
that the rockets being fired from gaza
were that predated that came before
israel's response in terms of attacking
targets in gaza
so as i said israel has the right to
defend itself but as i said at the
spatchbox yesterday
we expect that in doing so they abide by
international humanitarian law that they
minimize
civilian casualties and they act
proportionately that's always been our
position
but ultimately what we're seeking to do
is bring this conflict to a conclusion
president biden's sending an envoy is
that going to make any difference at all
well we uh the uk
are international partners both in the
region and more
further afield we'll continue to work
together to
use our diplomatic efforts to bring this
to a conclusion that's what that's what
we are working on uh working on
as i say both in terms of our direct
relationship with
uh the israelis and the palestinians but
also through
uh international partners as well
i mean benny goetz who's the defense
minister said yesterday
there is currently no end date for the
operation only when we achieve
complete quiet can we talk about calm
well i mean realistically that's
going to not going to happen unless they
bomb hamas out of existence
well as i say we have called upon hamas
to
stop their indiscriminate firing of
rockets into
israel um and so there is
a route to back towards peace no one is
pretending this
is a simple situation it's sensitive
it's complicated but ultimately we will
use every effort to to encourage a
de-escalation
and to get back to cooperation
and peace look can i ask you about the
the pandemic situation
it's our understanding sage the sage
group are meeting today i don't know if
you can confirm that for us
particularly concerned over the indian
variant
how worried should we be at this stage
well obviously some of the scenes that
we've seen uh in india itself are
heartbreaking and that's why
the uk has done uh so much to support
our friends in india with
the oxygen supply that they needed
obviously our genome sequencing
capability here in the uk is a
global class and we will be helping
india and indeed all partners
understand these variants better we have
very robust and we have had for some
time now very robust
border control measures whereby people
need to be tested
uh before arriving in the uk and
quarantine when they do
if travel is but it's already here it's
already here isn't it we know that
some of the covered hot spots and
particularly bolton
they think is is very much linked to the
india variant
well as i say we've got a world-class
genomic
sequencing capability here in the uk we
have a
huge number of uh tests and of course we
have
an incredibly effective vaccination
program so
um obviously we keep a close eye on all
variants
we want to make sure we're always basing
our decisions on the most
up-to-date scientific data um
but we we we have seen incredibly
positive numbers
um because of our vaccine program we
will be keeping a close eye
on all variants to make sure that we
move forward appropriately
and safely i know the scientists are
looking at this
all the time but certainly the european
medicines agency now their position at
the moment is
that they seem to think mrna vaccines
can neutralize
this strain which which seems to be very
very easily spread
but i mean that includes pfizer and
moderna but
not astrazeneca not the astrazeneca jab
which works in a different way so
there's there's potential of a lot of
people in the uk being left vulnerable
to this isn't there
well as i say we always make our
decisions based on scientific
evidence we have amazing scientific
capabilities here in the uk
and all our decisions will be based on
science on evidence
and in conjunction with as i say this
genuinely world-class scientific
community
that we're privileged to have here in
the uk
one of the the the four tests the key
test in moving down the
the road map out of lockdown is is
looking at variants of concern of which
the indian strain is
is definitely one one member of the sage
group telling the telegraph today that
although they think things will go ahead
on monday as expected they've got real
concern that actually
that the sort of total relaxation
towards the end of june
may now not happen well the sage
uh the scientists and scientists on
stage will make their assessments they
will
report that to government and we will
make decisions based on the
data and the evidence that they provide
the prime minister
the health secretary always been clear
that the easing of restrictions which
allow us to get back to a normality
will be done at a pace and in a way
which is safe and we will always be
driven by the data
minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you
now still to come on the program this
morning as the prime minister announces
an
independent inquiry into the pandemic
we'll speak to one campaigner who says
it needs to begin much sooner it's sort
of slated for
at the start of next year we'll talk to
her at half past seven
one of the most senior judges in england
lord justice fulford will be with us at
20 past
eight as new proposals for sentencing
child sex offenders are introduced
and the author josie lloyd joined the
women's running group in brighton after
her cancer diagnosis
her running pals went on to inspire her
new book
and we'll talk to her at half past nine
the former prime minister david cameron
will appear before a parliamentary
committee today to explain his
lobbying of cabinet ministers on behalf
of the finance company
greens hill capital david cameron was
employed by green sill as a part-time
advisor in 2018.
during his time with the company he
organised a private drink with the
health secretary matt hancock
and the founder lex greensteal now as
the pandemic began david cameron made
contact with government ministers
including the chancellor rishi sunak and
cabinet office minister michael gove and
senior civil servants like tom scholar
at the
treasury to try to persuade the
government to allow green sill
to become an accredited lender of
government-backed loans as part of the
corporate
covid financing facility this week we
saw some of the text messages sent by mr
cameron to the chancellor
asking if he could give it another nudge
over the finish line
and to mr gove asking him to to call to
discuss
business for green hill saying i'm on
this number
and very free and then to sit on
scholars saying he was genuinely baffled
when green sill
was not accepted to provide these loans
calling the decision
bonkers and saying he was going to text
everyone
all those efforts were unsuccessful and
in march greensville capital
filed for insolvency well let's talk to
our
political correspondent rob powell i
mean he was unsuccessful in all of this
lobbying
ultimately rob so well i mean what are
we likely to hear from david cameron
today
i think there'll be questions stephen
probably focused on three broad areas
the first will be his employment with
green sill after he uh
left government after he quit as prime
minister
and how much he knew about the financial
difficulties that green sill capital
was in of course it collapsed earlier
this year the question is did he know
that things were on the rocks when he
was still trying to
approach ministers and officials to sell
their services to get in
to these coveted loan schemes and was
that part of the motivation
for the increasingly looking at those
text messages desperate tone to try and
get
green cell access to these schemes i
think we'll
we'll also hear a lot about um going
back to 2012
and the role that lex green sill the guy
that founded this company
what role he had in government when
david cameron was prime minister
it's not a lot of clarity about what
exactly he did why he was brought in
what his role was whether he was given
access to sell his own services into
government
and then i think we'll have maybe
broader questions about the lobbying
rules more generally of course david
cameron has already said
he doesn't believe he's done anything
wrong i think the question is whether
the rules
are really tight enough whether he
regrets what he did
and don't be surprised if someone brings
up that 2010 comment that david cameron
himself made
when he referred to lobbying as the next
big scandal okay rob thank you
now a proposed new sentencing rules for
child sex offenders are expected to
propose
tougher prison terms even when there's
no victim
now the new guidelines would mean
harsher sentences for those who groom
victims online
even if their fake characters created by
police the former leader of the scottish
conservatives ruth davidson has
criticized
government plans to make photo id
compulsory for voting at general
elections
she said the idea that the plans were a
priority was
for the birds researchers say they've
discovered only mild side effects after
giving patients two different doses of
coronavirus vaccine
a team from the oxford vaccine groups as
well volunteers in their trial
suffered chills and fatigue there were
no major safety concerns
the prevalence of coronavirus cases in
england has halved since
march and it said it's lower since
august
a study by imperial college london says
the reduction is due to the success
of the vaccine rollout
senior dentists are warning patients
could be doing irreversible damage to
their mouths by ordering
diy treatments such as aligners
online let's talk to our reporter hani
shisethi so diy
dentistry hannity shirt not a good move
apparently
apparently not well dental liners have
become
quite popular especially with people
wanting that perfect smile
and because technology has improved over
time a lot of people have been able to
access this type of treatment
from home but the worry is though that
if treatment isn't conducted
properly this could compromise patient
safety
and it's why the general dental council
have released a set of guidelines
in summary they're saying that patients
need to be assessed
and fully assessed by a dentist and
they're also saying that direct
dentist to patient interaction is the
basis for informed consent
and also that patients must know the
name and registration number
of the dentist responsible for their
care now the british dentist association
is saying that they've seen an
influx of people visiting dental
surgeries with additional problems
all because of this absence of
face-to-face interaction
and we've been speaking to specialist
orthodontist dr patel
who describes some of the health issues
faced
okay halle shirt we'll hear from dr
patel a little bit later on i'm sure but
for now thank you
now the value of bitcoin has fallen by
about seven percent
after the car company tesla said it
would no longer accept it
as payment just months after investing a
billion pounds in the currency the firm
said it was concerned about its
environmental impact
the royal mail has issued four new
stamps to honor the duke of edinburgh
the black and white images show prince
philip through different stages of his
life
a plane was nearly ripped in two after
it collided with a light aircraft in
colorado
police say no one suffered serious
injuries after the two aircraft crashed
as they tried to land at an airport near
the city of denver
no injuries on that is phenomenal quite
how that managed i
do not know okay let's see what the
weather's going to do for you today
good morning joe wheeler what have you
got for us
good morning stephen uh well i'm afraid
it's not desperately good news it's not
desperately bad either it's just
unsettled over the next few days so you
can expect rain or
showers one way or another temperature
is pretty much what you expect this time
of year
it's just the detail each day which
changes a little so let's take a look at
today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you yes our
focus today is this area of low pressure
which is tracking
along the east the south coast it's not
going very fast
and that means the rain isn't going very
fast either and it's going to really
circulate
around this area of wales and the south
west now devon and somerset
likely to be affected there's a warning
out there mostly because the rain
continues through the day so we're
looking a lot of standing water
surface spray not very good for driving
but just to the west of that cornwall
should see some lovely sunshine
along with the silly isles elsewhere dry
start to the north and the west but
showers bubble up
during the day much as we've seen over
the past few days
and these could be heavy over parts of
northern ireland northern england
temperatures
at best around 16 or 17 celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we'll talk to campaigners
who say the public inquiry to the
government's handling of the pandemic
needs to start
much sooner than planned
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be
in the danger zone
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside
we know that 800 000 people have been
displaced i think experiencing the 2
million person march in hong kong that
was a moment
[Music]
sky news bangkok
so
[Music]
now the foreign office minister james
cleverley has told sky news the
government is working
very hard to resolve the current crisis
in the middle east
hamas militants have launched a series
of rocket attacks at israel
after israeli strikes killed commanders
in gaza speaking a short time ago mr
cleverley
said the british government had held
talks with both sides
to try to end the fighting i've spoken
to the respective
ambassador and the representative of the
uh palestinian uh authority in the uk
and the ambassador to
israel we're speaking with international
partners we are we are working very very
hard
to take the attention out of this
situation to encourage both sides to
step away from what could be
a a terrible escalation
and to resume cooperation get back to
the negotiating table because it is in
nobody's interest
for this to escalate further
well let's talk to our foreign affairs
editor deborah haynes who's in jerusalem
a lot of international pressure building
deborah but
is anyone over there listening
well i guess a really good question but
you're right the diplomatic
momentum has shifted and it is becoming
um a lot there's a lot more effort going
on now to try to
bring this back from the brink i mean we
had that warning yesterday didn't we
from the un warning that there would be
an a threat of all-out war
if de-escalation didn't happen but in
terms of the actual
facts on the ground there's no sign at
all of
any um let off in this exchange
of aerial bombardments we've just been
told
by the israeli military in terms of the
number of rockets fired
into israel towards israel from gaza
it's more than 1600 rockets in just the
last three days
of them 400 fell short but the others
came into the israeli airspace 90
percent
knocked down by the defense systems but
obviously
some got through and then on the
military side for the israelis they said
they've hit
more than 600 targets in gaza
taking down some three multi-story
buildings killing at least 10
senior hamas commanders and in terms of
the operations going forward
there are troops massing at the borders
israeli troops massing at the borders
uh there's reports in the israeli media
that there could be approval
for plans for a ground offensive but
we're not there yet
just if if plans are approved doesn't
mean that they go in but clearly it's an
option on the table
okay deborah thank you now relatives who
lost
family members to coronavirus have
criticized the government's plan for a
public inquiry into the pandemic
they're concerned that the hearings
won't start until next year
at the earliest well we've been told
sort of spring 2022 well let's
talk to the co-founder of families for
justice joe goodman and joe lost her dad
just over a year ago it's good to see
you this morning
why is trying as the prime minister said
trying to look at this
once we've got through the pandemic not
a good idea in your view
i think first of all we're really
pleased that the prime minister has
finally committed
to a statutory inquiry into the handling
of the pandemic
this is something we've been calling for
for a year now so most of the time since
i lost my dad i've been involved in
campaigning
for a statutory public inquiry into the
handling of the pandemic so i think it's
a really positive step that finally he
has
committed to that and given a timeline i
think from our perspective
it is really disappointing that the
timeline is is
so long um we were calling for a rapid
review phase of the pandemic to happen
last summer so we could learn the
lessons of the first wave of the
pandemic all of us who lost loved ones
at that stage um to be applied you know
when the the second wave came and sadly
that didn't happen and we saw that
you know there were there was even more
deaths in the second wave than than
there were in the first and i think
for all of us that that was really
devastating to look on and see that so
the prime minister gave the rationale
that the pandemic isn't over and we need
to be ready for potentially
further waves of the virus over the
winter which is something that
we agree we absolutely need to be
vigilant on but we also
really strongly believe that we have to
take the learnings
that have come up until this point
through if we do face further waves
but the the the process seems to be
going well so far in terms of i mean
certainly the vaccination rollout is
frankly extraordinary on this on the
scale that it has been carried out so
far
it isn't there some legitimacy to his
argument that the
government needs to really focus now on
continuing that program and getting it
as completed as possible
by the deadlines in order to try to
prevent a third wave
yeah i mean absolutely i think the
vaccination program has been one of the
successes and the nhs has done an
incredible job of rolling out the
vaccine
um this is something that we think can
be done alongside what is happening and
you know a lot of the reasoning that was
given by the prime minister was that
frontline staff don't have the capacity
for an inquiry
um actually this exercise isn't
primarily about
frontline you know it's important that
frontline staff testimony
is part of the inquiry um but that's not
what's needed you know we need to start
setting the inquiry up setting out the
terms of reference selecting the chair
um and starting to to preserve evidence
and take evidence and actually
frontline groups for example the british
medical association have been really
supportive of the need for an inquiry to
happen on an urgent basis
exactly so that we can ensure that
frontline staff are never under the
kinds of pressures
that were seen for example in january
this year
it's fair to say though isn't it that i
mean that this isn't a static situation
i mean
there are you know a number of internal
reviews constantly going up in the
huffington post talking about the
one considerable sort of internal review
taking place in the department of health
it's not as though the situation isn't
evolving from the way we're tackling it
is it no i mean
it's really disappointing as well that
yesterday at the same time as talking
about the need for transparency through
a public inquiry
the government refused to release its
secret report into lessons that have
been learned through the pandemic
when we first wrote to the government
calling for a rapid review
public inquiry we were given a long list
of all of the ways that lessons were
being learned
and as i said in the second wave it was
very clear
and actually for our group welcoming new
members on a daily basis who
had just lost loved ones whose stories
looked almost identical to those of us
who'd lost loved ones in the first wave
that it was hugely clear that
you know many of the lessons that could
have been learned hadn't been
um or at least hadn't been adequately
and it was costing lives and
we don't want to see more lives lost
because we're not learning lessons we
understand that the full length of an
inquiry
you know will take at probably a number
of years
but we also believe that it needs to
happen you know there's no reason to
delay
um kicking off an inquiry so that that
process can begin and we can't see how
anything can be more urgent when we have
a road map
for other you know restrictions being
lifted um
you know in just over a month we're told
that all restrictions will be lifted but
at the same time we're told that
the inquiry won't be able to happen
until next year it's quite hard to take
for families that have spent a full year
calling for this inquiry to happen
and you know really with a focus on
saving lives
um so that other people don't have to go
through this it's a really really
horrendous way to lose someone when you
know that it could have been preventable
and i think
for people who are losing people now or
who lose people in the
in the future knowing that you know
the opportunities to learn those lessons
haven't been taken until
after the fact um it's very hard to take
okay joe goodman it's good to talk to
you this morning thank you
thank you now more cases of the indian
variant of covid19 is thought in part be
down to the dramatic spread of the virus
in india itself and sky news can reveal
that the decision to hold elections
there
looks to have cost that cost the lives
of many teachers who were forced to work
in polling stations
well in uttar pradesh the country's most
popular state
two-thirds of cases are in small towns
and villages
our special correspondent alex crawford
traveled to one village
where the nearest hospital is more than
an hour away
in kanpur
they're marked as a house of death and
disease the barricades a silent reminder
to the village that coronavirus is
inside
sarita singh took selfies whilst working
at the local elections in uttar pradesh
she was among hundreds of teachers
ordered by the government to run the
polls
if they refused they risked losing their
jobs
these pictures given to us by teachers
show just how packed it was
by this stage india was already setting
global records for coronavirus
infections
within a week of returning sarita was
ill and struggling to breathe
the teaching union say she was one of
more than 700 teachers in the state who
died from coronavirus
after being ordered to work on the local
elections
uttar pradesh has a population the size
of britain france and germany combined
and has been one of the region's worst
affected microvirus
but we found little evidence of anything
like lockdown
nearly three-quarters of the population
live in rural
india and this state is traditionally
the heartland of support for the
governing bjp
party but now prime minister narendra
modi
is facing criticism at home and abroad
for focusing on the polls
and not the pandemic we traveled to the
village in uttar pradesh where sarita
lived
the teacher's family is not only in
mourning for her but when we arrive at
the home which is now
cordoned off one of her sons who
deliberately keeps his distance
tells us that both his father and
brother have been told they have covered
and the rest of them are all showing
symptoms
we decided to put on some protective
clothing because we're going into a
house where two people are positive
other people are showing symptoms we
want to
protect ourselves also make sure we
don't take the virus
out with us there's a lot of fear in the
village now
the only hospital is nearly two hours
away and that's if you have a vehicle
most here don't sarita's family begged
her not to do the election work
but told us the teachers had been warned
they faced being arrested
if they didn't do their civic duty yes
today mother's
m
foreign
her own mother who's feverish and has a
cough now
is distraught
the family have been waiting nearly a
week for the results of their own covet
tests
and they took sarita to two different
hospitals for help
but couldn't get a test for her straight
away and couldn't get her admitted to
hospital without one
these are the results of the coronavirus
test which she took on may the third
it's
positive she'd suffered seven days of
symptoms by this time and she only got
the result
the day after she died so she was never
registered
as a coronavirus death five other
households in the village are now
suffering
the elections here and across the
country have become super spreading
events
taking the virus into areas largely
covered free before
and leaving plenty bitterly doubting the
prime minister's
lead role in campaigning with such a
high human cost
alex crawford sky news in uttar pradesh
well still to come for you on sky news
breakfast this morning doctors are
warning of a tsunami of patients
as the nhs in england prepares to
publish
its latest waiting times
[Music]
well the paralympics are amazing but in
reality
they're only for a very small number of
disabled people about one in five of the
population
have some form of disability or
impairment and
the wider issue of sport and physical
activity is for
so many more people so we know olympics
paralympics might inspire some people
but
it doesn't inspire everyone and
pre-pandemic
there was a big gap in terms of disabled
people feeling they could be active
and the pandemic has has made that uh
much more challenging uh where you know
seven out of ten disabled people said
they they believe that pandemic is
has affected them quite badly um and we
know it's not just in sport terms but
in sport physical activity terms it's
it's made it harder
because we know that you know it can be
harder for disabled people to be active
you know i just know from my personal
experience um
it's not that easy necessary to go just
pushing around in my day chair
because of pavements or because people
parked on pavements or because of
uh you know sort of unlevel pavements
things like that you
you can't just necessarily do things the
same way you know from previous activity
alliance research we know that you know
there's a a fair worry from disabled
people
about being seen to be too active um and
and we've got to change our mindset on
physical activity actually
that actually recognize we need a whole
new approach to physical activity for
the whole of the population actually
because you know as we come out of that
pandemic being physically active is even
more important than
than it's ever been um but it needs to
change through school through access to
pe
through joining clubs uh and it's it's
about encouraging disabled people
themselves
to feel that they should be active and
and they're welcome so
unfortunately there's not one thing that
that we need to change but i think
what's really important is we
we now have data that shows the concerns
of disabled people
and you know that more disabled people
want to be active
they just need to be able to find the
ways to be active
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to the
safety ridge on sunday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it's a frost-free morning for much of
the country but we do have some heavy
rain over parts of wales
and the southwest mostly for devon and
somerset
cornwall the eyes of scilly likely to
stay fine through much of the day and
that
rain will spread across other
southernmost counties and turn showery
meanwhile there'll be a fine start to
the north and the west but showers
developing some of these heavy and
thundery over parts of northern ireland
and northern england terms of the pollen
count moderate for most but we could see
high out towards east anglia
the pollen reports sponsored by phillips
connected air purifiers
our french fishermen are warning their
livelihoods are at risk if they continue
to be banned from the waters around
jersey
it's a week now since the royal navy was
deployed in the english channel
following a dispute
over post-brexit fishing rights helenan
smith reports
the anchors were up before dawn so were
hopes for a good day at sea
the last time this boat went out it
wasn't to fish
but to fight their target new licenses
to work around the waters off jersey
waters they say now restricted their
long-standing rights reel them
and it's the sand shell and seaweed its
scallops they seek
they'll land over a ton just today but
they prefer to be fishing
in jersey's deeper waters
[Music]
for four generations every man in
baptist's family have fished
he'd normally work in jersey waters a
hundred days in the year
his new license gives him just 22.
foreign
he says it could cut his profit by half
this is hard ruling work and the margins
are already very tight
french fishermen say all they want is a
continuation of what they've always had
they've fished in these waters for
centuries if jersey doesn't back down it
could put many of them
completely out of business
but jersey's not backing down and the
french are retaliating
jersey fishermen now being barred from
numerous french ports
tit for tat escalation frustrating both
sides
the concerning thing for me is the
future of the fishing industry in jersey
because because of brexit we've got a
golden opportunity to change things
and to be on a more than even playing
field at the moment everything is geared
towards the fringe
it's totally one-sided and anyone can
see that
but the trouble is people aren't hearing
the truth about what is really going on
the eu backs france but intervention
would take
time time baptiste says
[Music]
politically there's still lots to unpack
two proud fishing cultures that can't
both have their way
fishermen can do little but wait
helen ann smith sky news normandy
now nhs waiting time figures for england
will be published
later this morning gps are already
warning of a tsunami of patients they
say delays caused by the pandemic means
millions are now waiting for treatment
well
let's talk to danny mortimer who's chief
executive
of the nhs confederation good to see you
this morning look i mean obviously the
figures are going to be pretty bad
because of the the the pandemic
situation there's there's no avoiding
that but just how bad
are you expecting them to be
there's a couple of things to say
stephen um i think the first is that
what we did see in the wave of the
pandemic after christmas was that the
nhs
did maintain uh its elective services
its surgical services
far more uh than we were able to do in
the in the first wave so whilst
we were much more affected by
coronavirus we also maintain those
services
but yes undoubtedly we will see the
number of people waiting and the number
of people waiting
far too long uh increase um
at the same time of course the nhs is
straining everything you to make sure
that it can bring those numbers down
some extra funding has been announced
this morning that will help some areas
accelerate
changes that are being made across the
nhs to address that problem
but in the short term those numbers will
increase and of course we also know
that as well as uh unfortunately being
able to treat fewer people last year
because of the pandemic
fewer people also came forward for
treatment because of the pandemic and
we're waiting to see
probably over the course of this year
what the impact of that 20
reduction in patients who came to their
gp and came through to hospital for
treatment
and what that will feel like if those
people do start to come forward for
treatment now
i mean i guess part of the problem here
is it's not just about money this 160
million as you say that's gone to
to tackle waiting lists announced this
morning but the problem is the staff
isn't it i mean you you can't possibly
make the staff work any harder
um no and and you know let's be clear
that the staff are working enormously
hard they are as
as upset and concerned about the the
scale of this challenge as
as they were about the challenge that
was presented by by covid
and there are challenges in other parts
of the nhs as well in mental health
services in general practice as you've
touched on and
we know there are patients that are
going to need long-term care because
they've got
covid there are things though that those
staff are doing
that are about innovation that are about
working differently and
organizations working together there are
some things
that may change in the coming months and
we may see
some of the infection control policies
that we we rightly follow because of
kovid
and just changed slightly which would
help throughput
we would also call on the government to
to make more capital
available to the nhs to invest in its
facilities because that would
help but you are right the biggest
long-term problem that the government
must address
must address in the spending review
this autumn is the long-term deficit we
have
in our staff 88 000 vacancies at the
moment
in the nhs in england we've had that
kind of figure now for a number of years
and whilst the government are taking
some steps to try and redress workforce
shortages
they do need to commit long-term funding
to a long-term plan
and both to give us the resilience in
the longer term and frankly stephen to
deal with this issue
but also to give staff hope in the
shorter term that they do have that plan
that there is a way forward but but all
that seems to point to the
mean even if that was all made available
immediately you're not going to get
people in place immediately
so i mean this is what inevitably going
to take years to address this backlog is
it
yes sadly it sadly it will um again
i would want to reassure your listeners
that the nhs is
is doing everything it can to get to
people as quickly as possible and in
particular
to get to the sickest patients the
people who need the care most urgently
as quickly as possible but yes this is
again sadly upsettingly this is going to
be a problem that's going to take many
years
for the country to to redress um there's
a report in the papers this morning that
gps
are being instructed not to see patients
face to face for initial assessment so
in effect to do
triage entirely online now some people
perhaps the older generation
aren't necessarily going to be happy
with that but in in some respects
that could actually free up quite a lot
of time couldn't it for gps and make the
the surgeries a bit safer
and we've seen over the course of this
last year both in gp surgeries and in
and in hospital settings um much more
use of technology to maintain that
contact with
with patients um relating to their care
or relating to the questions that they
they might have
and we don't think that's going to go
away and i think the announcement today
is actually just reinforcing what
clinicians across the uk are already
doing
at the same time and those clinicians
are also clear
that of course there are people who need
to be seen face to face there are
certain assessments certain things that
we need to do that can only be done
face to face and that that isn't going
to change and and there's also
a recognition that for for some parts of
society for some communities
access to technology isn't isn't as
straightforward as it might be for
for you and i um and again the nhs will
take steps working with local
authorities and others to try and
redress that balance but absolutely what
we are seeing is the use of technology
to try and improve that throughput to
free up a particularly
time for frontline clinicians so that
they can um
look at the the backlog of surgical
patients that we've talked about but
also
cope with the demand we're seeing um
increasing in community and general
practice as well
danny it's really good to talk to you
this morning thank you thank you stephen
okay let's get a quick check on the
weather for you with joe
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you well the
weather is looking rather unsettled over
the next few days through the weekend
and indeed into next week as well
there will never be low pressure very
far away today is the low pressure in
the channel which is giving us the worst
weather this rain over parts of wales
from the southwest
it's really just going to spiral around
and not go very far so parts of cornwall
the isles of silly will stay fine
throughout the day
it will break up and become more showery
but we'll also see showery outbreaks
into southernmost counties as well
whilst after a bright start for northern
and western parts we'll see showers
developing some of these heavy and
thundery
temperatures typically in the mid teens
celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways